So, das ist jetzt sehr spontaner Sache heute.
Äh, hallo, ich muss stream, äh, nicht stream, äh, steam, steam starten.
So ist das Game.
Ich hab eigentlich erst damit gerechnet, dass die Beta morgen online geht.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum die Beta schon da ist.
Warum ist die Beta schon da?
Was ist, was ist da los?
Kann man das hier mal erklären?
Der Rollstuhl-Hater.
Ja, das ist nice.
Kannst mich ja gleich haten.
So, gucken ob das Game startet.
Ich hab zwei Leute in der Liste, die spielen schon, also das muss gehen.
Warum?
Was?
Your computer appears?
Was will der?
Das Game fragt mich, ob es sich optimal konfigurieren soll.
Sag ich einfach mal, ja.
Game, konfiguriere dich optimal.
Dann mach mal Game Capture.
Und sagen wir wollen Call of Duty Capture.
Was nicht funktioniert, dann...
Ah doch.
Ha!
Krass.
Okay, ich mach mal Musik aus.
Nee, da kommt nix.
Äh, oh.
Moment, was macht mein Mikro da?
Call of Duty hat irgendwas an meinem Mikro rumgestellt.
Sonst, sonst wär das nicht so laut.
What the fuck?
But why?
Cort hat irgendwie an meinen Mikrosettings rumgespielt.
Wartet mal kurz.
Ja klar, das hat die Recording Levels einfach mal auf 100% gedreht.
Geil.
Super gemacht.
Das geht mir ja jetzt schon auf den Sack.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ist das okay von der Lautstärke jetzt?
Ist das, ist das okay?
Weil ich muss das jetzt grad wieder neu einstellen.
Das Next-Gen, ja das Call of Duty Konsolenport, lol.
Ähm.
Moment Leute, also ich werde jetzt meine 2 Stunden Streamingzeit heute erst mal damit verbringen, dass ich...
Allen Ernstes.
Daran sieht man schon mal, auf welcher Plattform das Ding standardmäßig entwickelt wurde.
Wenn ich vorplättern kann und scrollen, nicht mit dem Mausrad machen kann, sondern D drücken muss.
D, die innovat... äh, die, die intuitivste Taste zum Scrollen.
D.
Okay.
Jaja.
You may not.
Das ist, was, das muss ich wissen.
Eigentlich könnt ihr mich mal, sag.
GG.
Vollbild.
Hallo, Vollbild?
Ähm, jetzt muss ich mal in Stream gucken, ob er vielleicht noch was sieht, wenn ich Vollbild gemacht hab.
So, brightness, brightness, das muss immer...
Man kann übrigens brightness auch nicht mit der Maus verstellen.
Das lässt schon mal auf einen sehr guten PC-Port.
Ich muss übrigens noch in den Titel schreiben.
Wir schreiben...
Call of Duty...
PC Beta.
Done.
Also, man kann den Slider nicht mal mit Maus bedienen.
Das lässt mich schon auf einen äußerst guten Port schließen.
Settings, was gibt's denn hier so?
Gibt's einen FOF-Slider?
Gibt's das? Das ist wichtig.
Ich muss erst mal gucken.
FOF-Slider.
Opti...
Nein, nein, ich will das selbst einstellen.
Display Mo...
Moment.
Was macht das jetzt?
Jetzt ist der Bildschirm schwarz.
Window No Border.
Ja, das war angestellt.
Komm, wir lassen uns mal fullscreen.
Sicher ist sicher.
So, dann hab ich nämlich auch eine FPS-Anzeige oben und ihr habt auch eine FPS-Anzeige.
Ähm, Advanced Video.
Was haben wir?
Haben wir einen FOF-Slider?
Moment.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Maximum FPS.
Yeah.
Oh, nee, mehr geht nicht.
250.
Damit kann ich leben.
Screen Refresh Rate.
Wollen wir...
Allen Ernstes?
Hat jemand schon mal die allseits bekannte Refresh Rate von 119,98 verwendet?
Ihr müsst eine FPS-Anzeige da oben haben.
Bei mir schon einmal 62 im NVIDIA Overlay und einmal 63 im...
Ah, das ist das Steam Overlay, ne?
Das seht ihr nicht.
Ja, FOF 65 geht mal gar nicht.
Was ist das Maximum?
Äh, 90.
Gut, dann haben wir 90.
Pre T2X Resolution.
Aha!
Was auch immer.
Upsampling.
Das können wir eigentlich so lassen.
Äh, Auto, Auto.
Was haben wir denn sonst?
Post Anti-Alasing wollen wir nichts.
Kann man das vielleicht ausstellen?
Post Processing wollen wir nie haben.
Ähm...
Das ist alles an Grafikoptionen.
Dies ist jetzt nun wirklich Netz oder Wahnsinn, ne?
Na, Max Roll soll ich jetzt drei FPS-Anzeigen anmachen, oder was?
Ich kann euch sagen, was ich für FPS habe.
Vielleicht kann man das ja auch einplanten, FPS.
Ähm...
Moment, warum soll ich das machen?
Was jetzt?
Äh, das Game ist gecrasht.
Das Game ist gecrasht.
Ich hab nichts gemacht.
So, ich muss es wieder starten.
Das Game ist gecrasht.
Äh...
Ja, ich versuche euch irgendwie eine FPS-Anzeige zu organisieren gleich.
Vielleicht euch...
Hoffentlich hat das Ding jetzt meine Settings gespeichert.
Aha, Intro kann man auch wieder nicht überspringen.
Intro ist quasi gefakte Ladezeit.
Was?
Ah, deswegen muss ich restarten.
Restarten, okay.
Abdecken.
Alter, geht mir Gott auf den Sack mit dem Mikrofon umstellen.
Ich werde jetzt schon aggressiv, ey.
Das stellt wirklich das Mikrofon...
Das stellt allerdings das Mikrofon immer runter.
Auf...
Wieder immer rauf auf 100%.
Das ist...
Das ist hier...
So, überspringen, please.
Ja, hi an alle, die eingeschaltet haben.
Ich bin gerade noch ein bisschen mit dem Game beschäftigt,
weil es der Meinung ist, abzukacken.
Übrigens, das Zeug kann man hier nicht überspringen am Anfang.
Ihr müsst mir das übrigens ganz schnell schreiben, wenn ich zu laut bin,
und das Game wieder mal meine Voice-Geschichte...
Ja, okay.
Na, wir lassen das mal an.
Mal gucken, ob einer rumschreit.
Textured, ja, komm, wir lassen das alles mal an.
Push to Talk, ähm, lassen wir auf jeden Fall an.
Kann man Push to Talk-Level pick up, was auch immer.
Lassen wir mal so.
Ähm, okay, Graphics.
Hat sich das denn jetzt gemerkt, was ich haben will?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Das ist noch ein Schnelldurchgang.
Ähm, Maximum FPS 250, FOV 90, Post-Processing...
Nein, nein, nein, Post-Processing aus.
Textured Res...
Ich speichere erst noch mal.
F2, sehr intuitiver Knopf, F2.
Zum Speichern der Settings.
Ja, ja, Accept.
Was haben wir jetzt eigentlich? Jetzt haben wir hier...
Ich kann nicht mehr scrollen hier drin.
Okay, Alter, das ist ja da.
Komm, zu bedienen.
Ich muss mit der Tastatur bedienen.
Fill Remaining Memory.
Warum soll ich das machen?
Shader Pre...
Was auch immer.
Das lasse ich jetzt einfach mal hier auf Standard.
Standard ist das einzige...
Das einzige, was ich immer auspache, sind irgendwelche Blur-Effekte, falls welche gibt.
Das muss aus.
Ich kriege Anfälle vor Blur.
Okay, das lassen wir alles so.
F2, Speichern.
Also, ein...
Ups, F2.
So, mal gucken, ob ich irgendwie mit OBS, FPS-Anzeigen crappen kann.
Ich denke aber mal nicht.
Hm.
Hm, ich kann...
Ich kann Steam crappen.
Das bringt aber nichts.
Deckstory oder sowas habe ich da drauf.
Das wird dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht rendern.
Also, es gibt gerade keine FPS-Anzeige.
Mir fällt nichts ein.
Ja, mach es doch über Nvidia.
Ich habe eine FPS-Anzeige über Nvidia Rookie, aber ich sehe es halt nicht.
Also, ehrlich gesagt, ich sehe es schon, aber ihr seht es halt nicht.
Ich habe zwei FPS-Anzeigen.
Einmal von Steam und einmal von Nvidia.
Ich habe gerade 63.
So, wir suchen jetzt erstmal ein Game.
Das muss jetzt sein.
Bevor ich jetzt hier lange rumlabere.
Welcome.
Ich freue mich auch.
Oh, muss ich jetzt erstmal Tutorial machen?
Game?
Moment, ich muss euch mal was zeigen.
Ich zeige euch mal was.
Das geht gut los.
In den letzten 10 Minuten das Game schon zweimal gecrasht.
Yeah.
Bestes Game.
Lol, 3D.
So, nein, nein, nein.
Die Mikrofon-Settings sollte nicht einblenden.
So, ich starte es nochmal.
Ich hoffe, das hat meine Settings jetzt gespeichert.
Oh.
Moment, was will das Game jetzt von mir?
Moment, was will das Game von mir?
What the fuck?
Was?
Nein.
Nicht in Safe Mode.
Ich will das einfach spielen jetzt.
Hm.
Ihr seht doch die FPS.
Was erzählt er denn?
Ich sehe, oben links sind doch die FPS.
Wir hatten eben erzählt, dass man die FPS dann sieht.
Ich gucke gerade in die Vorschau und da sind eindeutig die FPS zu sehen.
Oh man, ey, das Game.
Ich kriege schon wieder Anfälle.
Das Game, wenn man mal das Mikrofon umstellt.
Ja, das liegt, da kann ich nichts für.
Okay, es hat wenigstens meine Settings gemerkt.
Dann suchen wir jetzt direkt Game.
Go, go.
Komm jetzt.
Bless RNG.
Bless RNG, Leute.
Hoffentlich läuft's.
Ist das jetzt Tutorial Mission?
Echte Aufnahme aus der Zeit, eindeutig.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass mein Opa Videos gedreht hat.
Grill.
Wisst ihr an was mich diese Videos erinnern?
Kennt ihr noch die alten Command & Conquer Videos?
Die waren auch immer so richtig fremdschirmmäßig gedreht.
Oh.
War geht.
Das ist der aus Battlefield 1, den haben sie sich geliehen.
So, wir gehen jetzt...
Ja, recrute mich.
Ich join, kommen wir join der Infanterie.
Oder, wem sollen wir join?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das für ein...
Wem joinen wir? Macht mal einen Vorschlag.
Wem wollen wir join?
Also, außer die Letzten, den Franzosen will ich nicht join.
Der Resistance will ich nicht join.
Airborne.
Einem Grill natürlich, also bleibt hier nur Airborne.
Airborne, okay, Airborne.
Okay, man sieht gleich, ich hab Anti-Alasing ausgestellt, das war vielleicht keine...
Oh fuck, hab ich noch...
Moment Leute, ich glaub, ich hab die falsche Auflösung.
Ich hab die falsche Auflösung.
Ihr müsst mir mal sagen, wie das aussieht gleich.
Ich hab nämlich noch 1080p.
1080p mit 30 FPS hab ich gerade.
Das könnte gleich in Bewegung ein bisschen scheiße aussehen.
Wenn das scheiße aussieht, stell ich um auf 720p mit 60 FPS.
Airborne.
Die Grease Gun.
Fragmentation.
Go, go.
Ah, übliche Layout.
Hm, ich will die.
Okay, die übliche Unlock-Geschichte, alles klar.
Ich hab nichts für das Ding.
Nichts.
Select.
Haben wir sonst noch was?
Oh, wisst ihr was richtig geil wäre, wenn's wirklich nur so wenig Waffen gibt?
Da wird mir richtig einer beabgehen, da können sich nämlich auch Wesentliche konzentrieren.
Ich würd gern jetzt einfach spielen.
Wie spiel ich denn?
Ich will nicht...
Nein, ich will nicht more learnen.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Kann ich das auch ohne machen?
Fight Match, geht doch da.
Hab ich Nachteile, wenn ich mich für den Kram nicht registriere?
Gibt's ranked?
Unranked.
Weiß jemand, ob's ranked erst ab einem bestimmten Level gibt?
Oder ob das einfach in der Beta keinen ranked gibt?
Bester Name hier.
Ich bin übrigens der 360-Node-Scope-Casual-Gamer.
Also, ich hab schon mal den passenden Name für Cod am Start.
Oh, es geht los.
Und ihr habt's ja gelernt in den letzten Pressekonferenzen.
Heutzutage ist man nicht mehr begeistert oder excited.
Heutzutage ist man mindestens super excited.
Also bin ich jetzt auch mal super excited, dass es losgeht.
Super excited bin ich.
All-new-Gameplay-User-first-Experience-noch-nie-da-gewesen-Player-first.
Was sind denn so die Ladezeiten?
Was macht meine SSD?
Die blinkt wie verrückt.
So, bashen, alter, bashen.
Sagt, ob die Lautstärke passt.
Hallo, wann geht's los?
Oh nee, gleich der Schneiber am Start.
Gibt's Friendly Fire?
Ah, natürlich nicht.
So, oh fuck, wie sind denn die Controls?
Hinlegen ist C, okay, jetzt muss ich umstellen.
Moment, C und Steuerung, okay.
Bashen, alter, bashen, bashen, bashen, bashen, bashen, bashen.
ADS geht ziemlich lahm.
Bashen, alter, bashen, bashen, bashen, bashen, bashen, bashen, bashen, bashen, bashen.
Die Sensitivity ist komisch.
Bashen, bashen, bashen.
Bashen, alter.
Jetzt bashen.
So, wie lang ist Hell's Wreck?
Gleich hier alles gebasht, alles gebasht.
Wie rennt man überhaupt?
So, gut.
Wo sind sie?
Ich muss bashen.
Der Sound ist gut.
Man hört die Gegner.
Ich bin begeistert.
Ich hör von rechts was.
Call of Duty Spawn System, null, man hat keine Ahnung, wo die Gegner sind.
Also alles verwalten.
Hallo, Gegner.
Wo sieht man meinen Ping?
Ping Anzeige.
Leute, das ist doch nicht euer Ernst.
Ping Anzeige gibt es nicht.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen oder was?
Ping Anzeige auf dem PC in 2K17.
Gibt es Optionen, wo man ordentliche Ping Anzeige einstellen kann?
Da ist er, da ist er.
Alter, kann ich mal einen Gegner finden?
Gegner, Gegner.
Ok, und endlich Sprinten gibt es nicht.
Gegner, suche Gegner.
Ok, da links sind Gegner.
Ich hör was von rechts.
Schreckt.
Oh, Flank, Flank.
What?
Er hat ja schon angefangen, bevor er mich sehen konnte.
Das macht Bock.
Aber Colt macht am Anfang immer Bock, bis die Sachen...
Wir switchen mal.
Was haben wir hier?
Wir gehen jetzt zurück.
Er kommt bestimmt oben.
Typischer Colt auf Duty, tot.
Äh, Colt, ja.
Tot.
Von der Seite geschreckt.
Steamauferle, geh weg.
Äh, wie kniet man sich hin?
So nicht.
Wie, wie...
Von der Seite.
Was, Max, man braucht kein Iron Side?
Warum nicht?
Ach, nee, Max braucht kein Iron Side, ja, das ist klar.
Ich würde gern mal das Scoreboard angucken.
Ok, der Typ da oben geht schon übelst ab.
Ok, von rechts kommt was.
Komm.
Wasch.
Auch geht nach.
Ah, ah.
Von hinten kommt was.
Oder?
Ja, von hinten kommt was.
Kann man hier, kann man hier auch raus aus diesen Cremes?
Ach, hier kann man auch raus.
Ach so.
Null.
Granate, was, Granate?
Äh, ok.
Destinate aller Zeiten.
Alle weg, sind alle down.
Nee, da ist noch einer.
Colt auf Duty, tot.
Von der Seite, typischer Colt auf Duty, tot, wieder.
Aber man muss einfach wissen, wo man stehen muss.
Ich glaube, das geht mit der Zeit.
Die Maps sehen hier auch relativ übersichtlich aus.
So, den Outplane, ich kletter da jetzt hoch.
Und auch in den...
Moment, das war nicht mal der Typ.
Das war nicht mal der Typ.
Alter, immer von der Seite gebashed.
Immer von der Seite gebashed.
Die Sens...
Die Sensitivity ist komisch.
Muss ich gleich mal umstellen.
So, und hier kann man jetzt raus und oben reinhüpfen, ne?
Nein, geht natürlich nicht.
Das wäre auch zu Colt auf Duty und Colt auf Duty-like.
Wenn man einfach an, an Stellen, die so aussehen, nach oben könnte.
Den holen wir.
Der ist tot.
Colt, ja, LOL.
Oh, Fritz, Fritz am Start.
Hä, war das ein Killstreak?
War das ein Killstreak?
Wir verlieren keine one on ones, ne?
So, wir verlieren keine one on ones.
Wir werden immer noch von der Seite gekillt.
Wir verlieren keine one on ones.
Oh, jetzt ist kein Gegner mehr am Start.
Sag doch, wir verlieren keine one on ones.
Ich höre was von vorne.
Kann man hier hoch?
Hopp.
Ah, wir verlieren keine one on ones.
One on ones verlieren ist auch für Loops.
Oh.
Was machen wir jetzt? Wir campen jetzt hier.
Wir warten jetzt, bis Fritz kommt und dann wird er crasht.
Kommt nichts.
Haben wir aufgeholt hier.
Roll of Duty tot.
Der freut sich.
Schönes Flanken, schönes Flanken, schönes Flanking.
Nice.
Geht schreckt an, schreckt.
Oh, wir haben Killstreak.
Wir haben einen Killstreak.
Okay, fuck, wie löst man Killstreaks ein?
Fünf?
Äh, äh, da.
Äh, äh, äh, vier.
Oh.
Bashing.
Und drei.
Okay, okay.
Was auch immer ich da mache, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, was ich da mache.
Aber ich bashe, ich bashe.
Guck hier, 18.5, GG.
Recon Assist.
Ich kriege, ich kriege.
Oh, ja, nice, bashing, bashing.
Bashing jetzt hier mit dem, mit dem, mit dem Maschinengewehr.
Kommt, Leute, kommt raus.
Kommt raus.
Reckt.
Das ist jetzt für die größten, für die größten Bobs hier.
Gucken, wo die langkommen jetzt.
Oh, oh, oh, ich glaube, die wollen hier rein.
Stimmt, hier rein jetzt.
Hä?
Also, die kommen von hinten.
Call of Duty Spawn, die kommen jetzt von hinten.
Typ, Typstein Call of Duty Spawn.
Hä?
Na klar.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt flanken wir, jetzt flanken wir hier neben rein.
Die Maps finde ich ganz gut durchdacht, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich weiche den Gegnern die ganze Zeit aus.
Ungewollt.
Was ist, was ist übrigens Messern?
Was ist Messern?
Ah, V.
Hallo, Gegner.
Wo sind die Gegner?
Da fuck.
Ich brauche Gegner.
Na, immerhin, immerhin, das war doch gar nicht so schlecht.
19.5 für erste Runde und kein Plastischimmer gab, was wir gemacht haben.
Ich habe es, guck mal, ich habe sogar Killcam.
Für diesen krassen Kill.
Der hat es, das war er.
Es war einfach der MVP Kill.
Guck hier, MVP.
MVP, nee, fuck, wie schreibt man das überhaupt im Chat?
Gibt es diesmal Server oder ist es kleinseitiges Haus?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Kann man während, kann man während der Runde sein Loadout ändern?
Private One.
Also auch Level 2 ist Private One.
Progression, kann man sein Loadout während der Runde ändern?
Kann man? Kann man nicht?
Kann man?
Ah, Continue, Continue.
Soldier, ah hier, jetzt kann man, ok.
Division, Airborne, ach Airborne sind quasi nur Kategorien für Skins und sowas.
Airborne.
Ich will die, ich will die Püpsch.
Püpsch.
Jawoll.
Oh hier, Fatse, Fatse im Team.
Echter Faceclan.
Landside.
Oh, geht los.
Wieder gleiche Map.
Ist Beta nicht erst morgen?
Doch, aber das war ihnen egal.
Laut Zeitplan ist Beta morgen, ja das stimmt.